our guests today have been BFFs I know
but they have been BFFs for over 30
years yeah they have and um they met on
a little show you might have heard of
90210 OMG
Kelly Taylor and I love this fun fact
back in the day they used to go on
double dates with their bad boyfriends
that sounds like fun all right everybody
it's
[Music]
we're so happy to be here oh my God
literally we were so excited
it's all coming through all right so
90210 was such an eye of a storm
so popular like such pop culture you
know and everybody had crushes on you
guys the girls and boys equal
opportunity everybody was like in love
with everybody it was like the time of
Bop Magazine and posters and like
Obsession how did you guys think about
that and whether that storm or were you
just like two girls in it grabbing hands
and living your lives when we were just
going full speed at the time yeah we
didn't know like we weren't as aware as
we are now acutely aware of like what we
went through and how we were able to
manage that but we just had to keep
going it made us stronger if anything
but I think to answer your question I
think we really didn't see all of that
we just did our lives and see I come in
the POV as like the fans screaming in
the mall yeah
and so it's so interesting to think that
in the middle you're just like going to
work you know in the middle of it
absolutely fascinating yeah oh my gosh
who knows if we would have survived it
we've been like acutely aware that
everybody was focused on us 16 17 like
do you mind going back there for a
minute though because yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
we never missed one episode
right now I'm like it was like a cold
but in a positive way we're up there
with you because on our podcast we're
watching it from the very first episode
as well for the first time in our lives
and we're on season four and I don't
remember anything that happened so I'm
like what is going to happen next week I
have no idea I love that you're doing it
so fun it's kind of so brave I mean
imagine if you could go back in time and
watch yourself 20 years ago you guys
think about that so it's Brave that
you're doing this and looking at it
Brave and amazing yeah we're like wow
look at them now it's great if you're
not if you're just trying to live your
life you don't really focus on it and
now you're older with this different
perspective and you're looking back and
your parents and like then you think
about what young girls are going through
like it's just it's such a wild surreal
full circle moment so I'm so glad you're
doing it because we all love it
[Music]
right we can ask anything about it sure
okay okay first of all I could never get
over how like skin tight and awesome
Donna's outfits were like it was full
midriff like teeny tiny and you're like
the most insane body yeah on those bike
shorts for days it was like bras and
bike shorts like how was that to sport
that look I mean I definitely look back
now and I'm like oh gosh I took all that
for granted like because I was so
scrutinizing I was really insecure then
like even 10 years ago I couldn't watch
myself back and now I'm able to watch it
you know when we watch our podcast and
watch that girl and I'm like that girl
was amazing and she should have been
secure and she was beautiful and look at
her and she rocked it and took chances
um and yeah I love my wardrobe from back
then oh my God it's so good and I love
that it's true we all look at photos of
like our haircuts we love you
it's a good thing that you're spending
time going back now and loving up those
outfits because we loved him at the time
obsessed with Donna and I was obsessed
with Kelly who went through a lot on the
show so much Amnesia she joined a cult
she almost got single white females what
was your most she did yeah right what
was your most famous uh Outreach
yes right there what was your like most
favorite outrageous storyline you named
them all I mean I loved every one of
them because it was just always an
emotional roller coaster not only on
screen but in my personal life too
but I know because that's the thing
you're like it's not that I'm on 902 I
know I've got stuff going on behind
I'm a human but I mean there were so
many I love I think probably the stock
or the single white female one that you
mentioned sure I remember she got her
hair cut just like Kelly yeah it was a
lot of fun but it wasn't just all the
crazy things that happened on the show
our show was like a Trailblazer a
Trailblazer in the fact that we dealt
with topics that weren't being dealt
with on television that's right at that
time for teens yeah what was one of your
favorite topics that you so boldly
tackled that wasn't being tackled at the
time and now obviously is incredibly
relevant but for you guys what was one
you're like I'm glad we touched on that
I mean so many were so far we've seen
addiction that we've talked about I
think date rape was one of the things
that Kelly went through that I think
really started a lot of conversations
for people safe sex at that time was
just not being talked about you also
tackled breast cancer cancer and um
being America's virgin yeah
like girls and boys used to come up to
me and be like you're a role model I
remember at the time thinking what is
that and they're like you show that it's
okay to be popular and be cool and still
be a virgin for men and women I was like
okay I like this yeah and Brian I agree
with hot I was like I don't know how
she's doing it I don't know you also
tackle to AIDS there was still a subject
that was not being tackled not openly
right no yeah so thank you for doing all
that yeah
[Music]